luego de estas acusaciones de los
fiscales de nueva york quienes aseguran
que el presidente protegió precisamente
a este narcotraficante que está siendo
enjuiciado allá de eeuu no se hizo
esperar la reacción a través de la
cuenta de twitter de casa presidencial
en un primer tuit pues se niegan
categóricamente la participación del
presidente hernández presuntamente en el
tráfico de drogas hacia estados unidos
cito textualmente dice la versión de que
el presidente juan orlando supuestamente
aceptó dinero de drogas de un giovani
daniel fuentes ramírez o dio protección
o coordinación a narcotráfico es 100%
falsa y dice twitter que está basado en
mentiras de criminales confesos que
buscan venganza la semana anterior el
presidente también tuvo su última
comparecencia en el parlamento hondureño
donde de igual manera desmintió estas
acusaciones desde finales
estadounidenses y dicen que
estas acusaciones están basadas en
mentiras de estos narcotraficantes que
buscan de alguna manera que el gobierno
estadounidense reduzca sus penas y que
además lo hacen en venganza ya que fue
precisamente cuando juan orlando
hernández era presidente del congreso
hondureño cuando se aprobó la ley de
extradición que permitió que todas estas
personas involucradas en estos actos
ilícitos fueran extraditados hacia eeuu
de igual manera dice casa de gobierno
que justamente eeuu reconoce la lucha de
este gobierno en contra del narcotráfico